but there is some information that's
missing from a step graph and this is
why I'm going to now return back to this
slot over here okay yeah what a great
question if I park and I'm driving it
well actually I'm not driving you have
to probably you pay before you actually
get to you you know the final thing
right and it's literally like the clock
ticks 60 minutes right the machine or
rather the car park has a choice right
which one is it gonna charge you do you
think I think I can safely put money on
the fact that they're going to charge me
twenty two and not eleventh because you
know why wouldn't they charge you $22
not to mention the fact that if you pay
and then you're gonna have to take a
minute to water you know you're pretty
much okay you mean you've given you'll
be given some kind of a window there
right now being that I've got this
hollow circle we've met these before
enjoying the number lines and
inequalities and that kind of thing I've
got a filled circle up here that means
that I've got a hollow circle an open
circle down here these points coincide
they are directly and now I will put you
they are directly above one another so
is this a function or is it a relation
it's a function because for every single
time you'll get one and only one cost
out of it right so I could stick the
vertical line test to this and know what
and I can keep on going the steps go up
like so
lots of expose to the same y-value yes
because I've got lots of times reading
here for instance like you know five
minute 10 minutes 15 and they're all
mapping towards that same towards that
same y dos so it's exactly right so what
we're thinking of here that the fancy
terms for this the independent variable
and the dependent variable right so it's
like you feed in a time and it'll give
you a cost okay so we're going from this
way to them and yes you can have
multiple values that way so I'll just
finish off you can see there's that
higher step there to get up to 60 bucks
and step again and then what happened to
you what should I put you
I should put narrow because you just
just keep going indefinitely unless they
tow your car away I guess
now one last little thing um and I'll
all agree that this is kind of open to
interpretation what happens here I have
an endpoint but I haven't said what
happens there what do you reckon closed
or filled now I'll say this this is open
to interpretation just as a personal
thing I would probably say or open the
reason why is because like what what
does that point actually represent you
have been in there now don't forget
right I know this is like a this is this
is why it's perfect to interpretation
this is a physical actual thing and now
when we cross over here this comes a bit
more abstract right what does this axis
represent this axis represents zero like
not I just got in that's an actual time
that the 0.000001 whatever what this
really means is zero minutes I would say
you haven't entered the car pocket right
well yes zero hours is also zero it's
like if it's really zero right like if
there's no rounding or anything like
that now I'll just say like I said you
could open to this nice to
interpretation and you could you could
fill that in if you interpret zero as
I've just entered but I would probably
say like if you've just entered then
sometime in the last anyhow I'm gonna
draw my my
sometimes the left okay now this is step
breath okay a step graph is a very sorry
no here's you come to toe a step graph
is a particular kind of a general type
of graph where like I've got all of
these holes in here I've got these holes
these things have technical names
they're called discontinuities
discontinuities okay
discontinue is because it's not
continuous there's a breaking there okay
more specifically these particular
discontinuities they're called
jump discontinuities because you jumped
directly from one value to another
there's no smooth change from 11 to 22
you just jump straight away up to the
next value so this idea of a graph that
has a bunch of discontinuities right
clearly there's a bunch of different
equations that corresponds to each of
these right like if I had a look at this
what would be the equation keep in mind
I don't have an x and y axis I have a T
and C axis what would be question of
this portion of the graph big C equals
11 and that ended BC equals 22 and C
equals 33 but this whole thing this
whole thing describes one situation it's
all one situation it's all one function
it is a function not a relation so
therefore this is a the step trap is
generally speaking what we call a I'll
put it over here a piece function a
piece meal is a very old-fashioned word
I it comes from if it does sound like a
meal um it comes from like piece work
like you get like bits and pieces
different separate sections of something
and these are the pieces that make up
this function these are also that the
technical name is a piece my spelling it
right I before a it looks funny if I
spelled it wrong
I started right the first time
the technical made for this but that's
full of science piecemeal peaceful is
what you can call these and no one will
have any ambiguity but the technical
phrase when it's just like
discontinuities a technical phrase with
this is a piecewise defined function
because what is the equation here right
it's going to be C is equal to and it's
equal to different things at different
times so what I do is I put in a curly
brace right and I say well okay
C is equal to 11 for a certain
restricted domain what domain at least
on my graph what domain 0 now let's be
really specific right because I've got
these boundaries here right I've got
less than and then T and then 1 right
and not inclusive right then I change
into 22 when do I change it to 22 at 1
and I include that and then T and then I
don't include
2 and I can keep going right 33 44 I'm
so close I might as well finish 60 and
then 77 for on my graph at least yeah
from 5 it just goes doesn't it it just
goes T is greater than equal to 5
ok so you can see and what I have is
these are the actual odds and these are
where those pots are true where the
pieces apply does that make sense